-Congratulations on anothe
season of "The Conners."
-Thank you.
-This is, of course,
a spinoff of "Roseanne,"
which you started --
you did nine seasons on
beginning when you were
13 years old.
-That's right.
-That is --
you were a very young person
and you grew up in front
of all of us.
-I was a very young,
awkward person.
It's hard to have your teenage
years in front of everybody.
-Yeah. In a weird way,
it's almost better
to start when you're 7 than 13
Like, that is --
-Right.
-...a trippy time to get
in front of people.
-Because then they saw you cut
before it went weird.
-Yeah, right.
-Right?
-At 13, it's basically, like
take quick look
because it's about to get
weird right today.
-Yeah, exactly.
-And were you aware of that?
I mean, being that age,
could you even comprehend,
"Oh, this is a very strang
place to be growing up"?
-Not really, because my family
was in entertainment.
So I think it was, for me,
it was weird not to do it.
-Sure.
-As soon as I started,
I was like, "Okay,
this feels correct."
-This is where you're
supposed to be.
-Yeah.
-You're suppose to be on a set
as a 13-year-old.
-Yeah, which is weird, but -
-But then -- and, of course,
you're also getting
an education.
Does that mean
doing homework on set?
Was that a big part of it?
-Yes.
So I was always jealous
because the older cast members
would get a break
when they didn't have a scene.
And the kids would have to g
to the schoolroom
and sit in a little room
and do work, so --
But now my kids on the show,
it's so interesting,
because I'm used to, you know,
"Oh, yeah,
it's time for school."
Their scene will end
and it's time for school,
and I'm like, "Oh, bummer.
And Ames, who plays my son
is like, "Oh, great. School.
And I'm like, "What kind o
imposter child is this?"
-Yeah.
-Right?
Like, "Who is this person?
But he's so brainy.
I mean, I look up to him.
-Do you reflect back
on yourself and wonder,
"Why wasn't I more into school?"
-No.
-Yeah, I see.
[ Laughter ]
Just put it totally on him
-Yeah.
-You -- I believe John Goodman
was here just yesterday
and he --
you used to be called
Scruffy or Scuffy?
-Scuffy.
What was the nickname
Scuffy for?
-So that was --
because I was a teenager,
I would kind of come in tire
with my shoes not fully on
slowly scuffing the set.
-Got you.
-So they would say,
"Oh, here comes scuffy,"
because they'd hear me
sort of scuffing in.
-Oh, you were --
so just the teenager --
-Yeah.
-...like, telltale stuff.
-You know, happy.
-Yeah, you were happy.
Was it surreal walking bac
on the set
after so many years away?
-It was crazy. The --
I was there for pre-production
so I was there while they were
putting up the set.
So the first wall
of the utility room went up,
which is like the back roo
that we didn't even shoot in
that much where
the washer and dryer are.
And it was just
one yellow wall.
And I -- it blew me away
just seeing this
one tiny wall that
was a few feet.
And then the whole set
of course went up.
-I mean, I guess
it would be that --
it would be as if someone
just rebuilt your childhood home
for you to go live in again,
and just watching it
slowly go up,
it must have been such a trip.
-Yeah.
-And then I've heard,
is it true that the couch
is not -- is the one thing
that is not the same couch
-It's not exactly
the same couch.
We actually found
the original couch.
Some guy has, like, a TV museum.
People think it's
in the Smithsonian.
It was there for a brief time,
but it's no longer there.
-And then this guy stole it.
-This guy stole it.
-Yeah.
-He Nic Caged the "Roseanne"
couch from the Smithsonian
-It's -- by the way, it's easy
to get a couch out, right?
-Right, exactly.
-To sneak out.
No, so he has a bunch
of memorabilia.
He had the couch.
And, for me,
it was really important to m
to get the original couch.
I thought that's, like --
-Yeah, it's --
-You have to, right?
-Obviously, like,
the very fact that it was
in the Smithsonian
tells you this was...
-Sure.
-...an iconic piece of --
-But then in order
to get the couch,
there were so many rules.
We had to have thousands
of dollars of extra insuranc
if we wanted to have
the couch on the set.
It could only be there
when we were shooting,
not on days where we were
just rehearsing.
And then it had to be taken out.
It had to be cleaned.
And it had to have its own
security guard, essentially.
-Really?
-Yeah, and I was like,
"This couch is more
important than I am."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, this is like --
So we thought that might b
too much.
-That might be too much.
-I still was like, "Should we?
I don't know."
-Well, I think --
everything I know about actors
and their egos,
you don't want to have
a piece of furniture around that
people are being nicer to
than the actors.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-No, that's true.
-That would just spin them out
-But the other thing
that was funny to the cast
we were like, "The couch
that we ate Cheetos on
and had our dirty feet on
is so" -- you know?
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, it's unbelievable.
But, I guess, there you go
It's a piece of Americana
history at this point.
-I guess so.
-You also --
You created the show "The Talk."
You left recently to work on
some other things.
When you leave a place like that
you've been for a long time,
and, obviously, I assume
you're very close
with the people
you work with there --
do you stay in touch
with everybody?
-Yeah. I think they must b
thinking like,
"Please leave us alone."
Because I left but I didn'
really leave.
I'm texting them,
"How did it go this week?
What is happening? Who's there?"
-Yeah.
-That's all right. When I left
"SNL," I did the same thing.
I was so -- I still wanted to be
super invested in that place
And then I realized they were --
they basically had to
eventually tell me --
-They move on.
-Yeah, and they're also like
"You know we're working, right
This is a workplace and we don't
need to tell you all day, like
how work is."
-Yeah.
-Well, congratulations
on the show.
It is so lovely having you here.
-Thank you.
-And looking forward to a ne
season of "The Conners."
Give it up for Sara Gilbert,
everybody.